so I guess just to start off with I
would say look there should be I would
say I want a service that the moment you
die someone comes in an unmarked van
steps over your cadaver and takes a
sledgehammer to your computer
oh I thought you guys said they're gonna
recite every since I'm hiding anything
oh okay
I've got nothing to hide I'm clean bro
I'm just saying that there should be a
service are you gonna like wipe your
computer just before the big moment
comes when you guys I you just as I take
my wrong twist
oh wait my computer it's a good last act
well as goodness how does how did the
film sort of affect your your views on
technology um you know they just
heightened my awareness that I'm more on
the compromises than I care to admit
mm-hmm you think you're not on it that
much but sure I mean I'm sure there's an
I'm sure there's a way for your iPhone
to tell you you spent two and a half
hours online and it's not 12 noon yet
there is an app there is an app that
does that okay that's scary well did you
ever look did you ever look at your
search history do you ever I don't know
if I do that what would why why would
you why do you say that I do I don't say
for any reason what would be thou clean
man no I know I know what do you think
is the number one thing you you search
for that's easy
ESPN um I'm an NBA fan so I don't know
what it's not even basketball season I
check I just my thumbs do it and I mean
so much of this movie is just you acting
in front of a laptop what are sort of
the challenges to staring at a computer
screen and looking natural I just
we're its opposite to everything I've
ever done which is to look at a person
in the face sure and that's how you want
to that's how you get the best
performances out of people because it's
harder to be inauthentic when looking at
a human being so yeah it was just weird
it was just I wasn't able to rely on
anything I've learned at this point
because it was all new what do you base
the performance on that if you don't
have you know another face you just try
to be specific and you didn't know what
the story is and you know I really
leaned on a niche because we I wasn't
looking at anything and so there's so
many plot points that you know we're
about where what I'm looking at so we
had to dramatize those and be specific
and really um the character David was
just not all that far off from me you
know he was someone who loved his
daughter and was stressed out and I
certainly can relate to that anxiety so
um you know what I could relate to I
just hung onto real hard what was the
most difficult scene to shoot for
yourself no boy you know any scene where
I was on the webcam and sort of dealing
with multiple revelations that was just
really hard because then there's one
thing that comes message comes in and
then I see a and none of those things
were on in front of me so that was hard
friend Joe walking and chewing gum I
guess but but you know multiple events
happening on the screen we're weird when
you get a script for say searching what
tends to be the first thing you do to
sort of find the character whatever for
me is whatever feels familiar and then
you start build on that so if he's in
this case it was just he's a dad and
that was it was really it
the the rest of it you know if I happen
to be a software engineer I would cling
to that but it's the dad part was the
one I was familiar with so I just look
for commonalities first I know you have
a number of other sort of thrillers
coming out what are you playing The
Grudge what is that sort of and The
Grudge I play boy I'm trying to now and
you're throwing me into a place where
I'm trying to what I'm trying that I'm
not supposed to say so if I sit to say
The Grudge is another like it's a
domestic I'm in Adam another domestic
stressful situation so it's that's a
good one
how similar is it sort of the Japanese
films and the American remake I think in
spirit it's very similar to the Japanese
the Japanese origins but this it's very
mature this filmmaker is very assured
Nicholas Pesche and I worked at Betty
Gilpin who's a really accomplished actor
it was really fun I know you also have
the o'the coming out that seems like a
lot of fun what is sort of the plot of
that movie and who do you what are you
playing the oath is a movie that wonders
what would happen if the President of
the United States asked everyone in
America to sign a loyalty oath okay and
what Thanksgiving dinner would look like
I knew who do you play in that I play
the agent that comes to the door on
Thanksgiving Day to ask for that
signature mm-hmm so so it goes well in
the movies it's over in times I have to
ask about a star Trak do you do the
powers-that-be ever give you any sort of
update on Star Trek I know everything
but I'm not gonna tell you I've told
every other journalist today I do these
are from you yeah thank you thank you
so you're shooting it out what else what
else do you have on the docket that's it
man you one more I'm taking over a
family feud
I'm or leasing Steve Harvey that's good
sure it's good I'm also replacing Steve
Harvey on The Steve Harvey Show oh is
we caught them The Steve Harvey Show I
like it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you